Let's talk about fun with using English.
Now, let's go to Kyoto.
I would like to introduce the old buildings in Kyoto.
This is Fushimi Inari Taisha Shrine.
It was built by Hata no Irogu in 711.
There are many torii gates.
This is Kiyomizudera Temple.
It was built by Sakanoue no Tamuramaro in 778.
The view from the building is very good.
This is Kinkakuji Temple.
It was built by Yoshimitsu Ashikaga, a Japanese shogun, in 1397.
This building is covered in gold leaf.
I would like to introduce about food in Kyoto.
Matcha and Japanese sweets are specialties recommended.
Bitter matcha goes well with Japanese sweets.
Thank you for watching.
Please visit our beautiful city, Kyoto.